[Musique]
d'ici quelques années
l'ancien pro shops disparaîtra du
paysage montréalais après avoir fait
place à la nouvelle structure
actuellement en construction
ce changement améliorera la vie de
nombreux automobilistes
mais pour d'autres voyageurs et les cela
ça représentera tout un défi on peste
contre ces bouchons de circulation et
les coûts exorbitants ces travaux
d'entretien d'ici quelques mois les
automobilistes pourront enfin de
l'abandonner pour quelques locataires à
plumes
la transition sera plus délicate le
vieux pont champlain et leurs lieux de
refuge et de reproduction
depuis le début des années 2000 un
couple de faucons pèlerins
j'ai à chaque été niché en otc piliers
et plusieurs centaines d'hirondelles à
front blanc ont élu domicile dans sa
structure la démolition prochaine du
pont les forcera à se reloger
la société d'état qui gère le pont
champlain a recruté une équipe de
biologistes pour s'assurer que le
déménagement se fasse en douceur dans
les baies aux conscrits plein
instructeurs qui vont ressembler à la
beatles il faut continuer sur son
éducation
par exemple un pont ou un grand grand
édifice dans un centre ville c'est une
paroi verticale fait de structure
rocheuse ont fait détoner j'peux se
ressemblent en falaise au mois de juin
un couple de faucons pèlerins vient tout
juste de mettre au monde trois oisillons
qui couve avec soin tout près de la voie
maritime
impossible de s'approcher c'est que le
sens pas proche à quelques mètres du nez
la fenêtre voir et territoriales à votre
défendent sont ni les jeunes qui sont
craintifs si nacelle par exemple la
bosnie pour nous montrer la bête de plus
près les biologistes ont amené shelby un
faucon pèlerin qui travaillent
habituellement à l'aéroport pierre
elliott trudeau à éloigner les oiseaux
indésirables des pistes d'atterrissage
plus petit que l'aigle c'est un oiseau
robuste connu pour ses battements d'aile
puissant et rapide
ses proies de prédilection ce sont les
passereaux et les pigeons pour lui la
ville et le garde manger idéal
à la fin des années 1970
le faucon pèlerin était au seuil de
l'extinction en amérique du nord
le ddt insecticide amincie c'est la
coquille de e
à tel point qu'elle se brise est son
poids de la mère dans les nids pour
sauver l'espèce on a interdit
l'utilisation du ddt au canada on a
aussi lancé un vaste programme de
reproduction en captivité
la population est en voie de se rétablir
mais elle reste sous surveillance pour
protéger le couple qui nichent sur le
vieux pont champlain
les biologistes ont installé trois
boîtes de nidification c'est un endroit
audard protéger des intempéries du vent
allait des proches vivant poire pomme c
est effectivement il est atterré par ce
genre de moi chaque printemps les
biologistes s'informent des travaux
d'entretien prévus sur le vieux pont
puis il place les boîtes de nidification
à des endroits stratégiques
ils veulent inciter les faucons aniche
et le plus loin possible du bruit on
passe par là bas en faisant des bardenas
y sort faut carrément y aller par le
haut qui on comprend que bloquer des
voies de circulation sur des ponts aussi
important c'est pas des choses trop
souvent
le futur pont champlain sera équipée de
nouvelles boîtes de nidification pour
inciter des faucons à déménager
normalement on a des bonnes chances que
le faucon adopte le nouveau pont avec
les nouvelles bon classement lors
pouvoir condamner les anciens gold pont
champlain pour faire une migration en
douceur la populations d'hirondelles à
front blanc inquiète aussi les
biologistes
depuis quelques années on soupçonne des
insecticides dont les néonicotinoïdes de
réduire le nombre d'insectes dont elles
se nourrissent
heureusement celle qui n'échoue pont
champlain sont en excellente santé
elle forme la plus importante colonie du
québec ont fait des suivi annuel à
l'intérieur de notre programme de
gestion de la vie fonde donc on suit la
notification et on voit que la compagnie
prend du galon avec les années on craque
les oiseaux installé sur le vieux pont
rechignent à coloniser la nouvelle
structure dont l'inauguration est prévue
pour décembre 2018
la structure du nouveau pont aura moins
de poutres moins d' angles droits et de
recoins où les hirondelles à front blanc
aime construire leur nid la société
d'état veut inciter les héros dans la
feront blanc a déménagé sous l'estacade
en amont pour y arriver on a aménagé des
poutrelles sous le tablier
on a fait bloc pour ancier ont été
capables d'imiter leurs l'unification ça
semble fonctionner et faut que ton était
patent de bloquer leurs lieux
mitigation l'année précédente pour
pouvoir avoir un transfert vers
l'estacade justement il leur suffira de
quelques battements d'aile pour aller
découvrir leurs nouveaux quartiers
[Musique]